JENNY BROWN: File storage
is a critical need
for many enterprise
applications and workloads.
But file storage is about
more than just disk space.
It's about finding
a solution that
is fast, consistent, scalable,
and still simple to use.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Some of the most
common use cases
for file storage in
enterprise applications
are media rendering,
data analytics,
and managing shared content.
These complex situations
require flexible and scalable
solutions.
Plenty of us have
heard it before.
Storage is cheap, but with
needs growing exponentially
to fit use cases like these,
companies want flexibility
to scale on demand and
meet specific performance
needs of their application
and user demands.
And now that
companies are turning
to cloud computing
solutions for applications
and for their
infrastructure, there's
a growing demand for
cloud-based file systems.
To meet the needs
of customers looking
for a fully managed
cloud-based storage product,
Google offers Filestore.
Filestore gives users a
simple native experience
for standing up managed Network
Attached Storage, or NAS,
for their compute engine
and Google Kubernetes
engine instances.
We also rely on file storage
partners such as NetApp
and Dell EMC Isilon
Today, we're going
to show you how to quickly
configure and attach your file
system to a compute instance.
Say we have an intensive
workload and many clients,
and high throughput is critical.
To begin, I'll name my instance,
for example, Performance Test.
Next, I have to
select a service tier.
Since I need a
high-performance application
with many connected clients,
I'll go with High Scale.
For help picking the tier
that's right for you,
you can check out
the comparison table.
The storage type for High Scale
is SSD, which works for me,
and with Basic, I would
also have the option of HDD.
I'll keep capacity
at 60 terabytes
and can always scale up or down
when needed without any service
interruption.
As I specify
different capacities,
I can check the calculator for
cost and performance estimates.
Now I have to choose a location.
Since my clients are
located in US Central 1,
the default location is perfect.
I can set a specific zone or let
the deployment decide for me.
Next, I'll select the
network used by my clients
so they'll be able to
access this file system.
Once I have a network,
I'll allocate an IP range
or let the service
do this for me.
The file system mount
point IP address will
be selected from this range.
Next, I'll give my
share a name, DCC.
This will be represented in
the mount location later.
Even though I can
grant or restrict
access to my file system
through IP-based controls,
I'll leave it open for now.
And now I'm ready to
create my instance.
Once it's ready, I can see
all my instance details
and copy the mount point string.
Now I'll SSH into a client
VM I already created
and mount my file system
using the mount point I copied
earlier to slash MNT directory.
Let's run some load and take
a look at the performance.
I'm starting with 256 clients
performing simultaneously
with intensive IOPs.
You can see the clients are
building their working set.
And here you can see
the latency leveling off
at 10 milliseconds and
IOPs reaching 150,000,
since my clients are
saturating the instance.
I need higher performance
and more capacity,
so I'm going to scale
up my instance from 60
terabytes to 320 terabytes.
After my instance scales up,
you can see the graphs start
to change.
Here the latency graph drops,
showing much lower latency,
and the IOPs graph is
climbing to 600,000 IOPs.
As we'd expect, the
total throughput
is also growing accordingly.
For anyone that's ever
managed their own storage
and panicked because they needed
to slap another physical drive
in a server before
they ran out of space,
this is pretty exciting.
Today, we saw how
Google Cloud file
storage is used to migrate
traditional applications,
modernize existing
applications with Kubernetes,
and scale to meet the
performance demands
of big compute workloads.
For media rendering to
genomics processing,
Google's file storage
can meet the needs
of business critical workloads.
Thanks for joining us,
and please check out
our website and
documentation to learn
even more about Filestore.
[MUSIC PLAYING]